uh  in terms of the world championship just  uh  do you feel like you have  achieved everything you set out to when  you when you started that journey  now and nine years ago almost  well it's more than nine years ago since  um since the since the candidates um  it's hard to say i don't think i had any  other goals than to win it once then  uh i thought  um  i'll  you know i'll uh i'll  try and keep it as long as  i'm motivated  that's fine to be honest  2016  i was not very motivated uh i feel like  i mostly played that much because other  people sort of  relied on it expecting me to which is  was was fine it was not their  fault at all it was all on me for  feeling that  um  response responsibility